the somerset town of frew may be picture
perfect but not on the political front
as their conservative MP David Warburton
has resigned triggering a fourth
by-election for the party
shop owner Gary says it's time for a
change
I get to speak to people on all sides of
the political
extremes uh and and every one of them
right and left have been extremely
frustrated with the situations Jeff is
feeling that frustration his mortgage
payments are about to cost him an extra
700 pounds he wonders if those in
Westminster are aware of the impact of
the cost of living for local people I
think they are quite
quite insulated from the rest of the
things the rest of us have to to go
through
the ongoing challenge for his son Gareth
is maintaining his Pottery business in
the current climate uh
like a nice luxury day out like
a bit of a desirable desirable option
when people have got food and bills to
pay they're you know they'll stop
spending in independent shops in a town
like this
Mr warpton says he was denied a fair
hearing by a parliamentary harassment
Watchdog investigating allegations that
he made unwanted advances towards two
women in his resignation letter he said
the obstructions I've outlined reveal a
spectacular level of disdain for any
search for truth and expose the
precarious vulnerability of Justice
inside the Parliamentary estate this
needs to be laid bare it needs to be
addressed
House of Commons spokesperson said they
couldn't comment on this individual case
but said Parliament remains absolutely
committed to the complaints scheme
meanwhile this constituency is in limbo
those we've spoken to say haven't been
the biggest conservative fans but there
is quiet and strong support in more
rural parts of this constituency the
challenge for the prime minister is to
keep Broome and Somerton blue before
2015 this was a liberal Democrat
Heartland so he will have a nervous eye
on them as likely challenges
young voters want someone to invest in
their futures
I'll be lucky if I have a house I'll be
lucky if I can afford to rent somewhere
so that loss of Hope and I think that's
widespread amongst everyone the eyes of
the world will be on this region next
week as it hosts Glastonbury Festival a
welcome distraction for them perhaps
until a parliamentary race that may be
quite the contest improve